un ataque con misiles durante la noche
en un barrio Residencial de zaporilla
dejó civiles muertos y heridos unos
cinco edificios de apartamentos quedaron
destruidos
[Música]
Cuando ocurrió la primera explosión No
entendí inmediatamente lo que estaba
pasando se oyó un rugido las puertas mi
hermano vino gritando despierta a los
niños los puse a todos en una cama y los
cubrí con todo lo que pudo encontrar
busque salir al exterior pero la puerta
estaba completamente destruida por la
onda expansiva se metió dentro de la
casa
esta federación rusa la forma en que
está haciendo todo esto operación
especial no creo que sea una operación
especial
como que no sé cómo transmitir esto para
ver cómo lo llaman esto definitivamente
no es una operación especial
cuatro centros educativos quedaron
parcialmente destruidos
no hay nada ni industria ni militares ni
fábricas militares Por qué nos
bombardean Por qué
las ciudades a por ella está a unos 52
kilómetros de la central nuclear del
mismo nombre la más grande de Europa que
permanece bajo control Ruso y que ha
sido blanco del asedio durante las
últimas semanas tanto Ucrania como Rusia
se acusan mutuamente de bombardear la
planta
Moscú dice haber anexionado la región
Aunque sus fuerzas no la controlan en su
totalidad
el bombardeo a la ciudad es el segundo
ataque de este tipo en tres días contra
la región el jueves murieron otras 18
personas la semana pasada el ataque
contra un convoy de automóviles dejó al
menos una treintena de